what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Avengers Beyond which we
forgot to finish and a lot of the guys
were asking what was going on in
relation to the lost one and the
beyonders and the celestials and how it
all ties in together with the current
Mythos okay this video will explain that
but we do a bit of a Time skip between
the end of the last video that we did
and the start of this one and what's
basically happened is the lost one has
effectively wiped out most of the
superheroes on Earth or at least
defeated them and really even killed a
whole bunch of them and in fact one of
the big things that you guys kind of
asked was that if this guy is so
powerful why doesn't he just like do
what some kind of crazy reality whipper
would do and just alter all things in
existence or something along those lines
well the way this is answered and I'm
curious to see how you feel about it is
we're basically just told power has
limits right this body I wear though I
fashioned it myself is still only as
capable as that for which it was
designed when I first conjured it eons
ago from matter and energy it was says
for all intents and purposes perfect I
could swim on the surface of a sun I
could fly through a black hole I could
shatter a moon with my fist and then my
power was stolen from me by beings that
are called the beyonders and that he's
basically been trapped in this body ever
since the bigger Point that's being made
here is that those individuals who can
alter reality or who have insane levels
of Power are largely limited by the
bodies in which they occupy which
actually makes sense and in fact that's
been a case in Marvel Comics for quite
some time it wasn't really overtly
stated the way that it's being stated
right now but it was one of those things
that you just kind of came to understand
right Franklin Richards could do all
kinds of fantastic stuff alter reality
on a universal scale mad Jim Jaspers
could do the same thing Matthew Malloy
could do it to a degree but he
resurrected himself from the dead and we
never really got the full totality of
what he was capable of but any one of
these guys if they were without a body
would be able to achieve ridiculous
things in Marvel Comics hence the nature
of embody bodies when it comes to the
cosmic entities if you don't know what
that is we'll talk about that here in a
little bit but the thing about this is
that what we saw at the end of the last
video is that as part of a kind of quote
unquote punishment which is to say when
the beyonders had initially stolen the
power of the lost one for themselves and
they in turn started perusing the cosmos
that what the main beyonder had done in
order to keep the lost when trapped on
Earth is he had kidnapped other
beyonders and then basically used them
as a kind of prison system siphoning off
their energy and so on but in effect he
turned against his own Kant the result
was that his power was stripped away
from him by the other remaining
beyonders and then he was cast down to
earth and that's why here in this moment
when he's approached by the lost one he
talks about how he doesn't remember
anything he doesn't have his powers he
doesn't know how the shield works or any
of that stuff because he doesn't right
like all that stuff was taken away from
him the idea behind the main beyonders
themselves is that they would basically
have the lost one trapped here on Earth
and that would affect actively be it and
so what we end up doing is picking up in
the ruins of what used to be the city of
New York again we never really saw how
New York fell we just kind of jumped
forward to after it was basically
destroyed and She-Hulk was tattered and
so on and so forth the big thing here
though is that what they had discovered
is that before the beyonder had
encountered the lost one in this story
what he had done was taken a portion of
his memory and put it within New York
City itself underground so that if
something were to happen he could
basically attain this portion of his own
memory and then figure out exactly what
needs to be done to set things back to
rights exactly why he did it I'm not
entirely sure and it looks like it's
being done just for the sake of being
able to tell the story but of course the
Avengers kind of asked him what do you
know about the lost one he of course
reveals the lost one's name as being
calhora which we already know and that
the question is is there a way to lower
the shield to get this guy off of our
planet now what Iron Man also does is he
Fashions a device to this orb that the
beyonder's memory is currently sitting
in and when the lost one shows up he
deduces that the nature of this item
this artifact is that it will basically
blow the orb up and destroy the memory
of the beyonder should the lost one
choose to use his powers and so what you
get is this really interesting Quagmire
here this really interesting situation
the lost one's been around for countless
eons right at the end of the day the
Avengers are just like superheroes on
Earth who do superhero things because
that's what superheroes do but depending
on where you stand in the philosophy and
morality of superheroes you could see
their goodness as a weakness and that's
how the lost one sees it right his
stance when She-Hulk kind of freaks out
when he says like are we here to Banter
or are we here to fight she makes this
statement and saying you killed
thousands of innocent people and his
response is actually it was tens of
thousands if you're going to talk about
what it was that I did at least get it
right right I mean I killed tens of
thousands of people not just like
thousands of people and where Thor
responds and saying we do not negotiate
with murderers the response to the lost
one is is but of course you do to save
yourselves and your planet you do it all
the time is what I ask unreasonable or
just merely distasteful what makes this
situation different than any of the
countless others where you've made
Bargains with villains where you've done
all kinds of things to work alongside
villains in order to make sure that your
schemes came to fruition a really good
example of this is during like the
incursions the collapse of the
Multiverse once you got to that
situation and everything was popping off
there was no differentiation between
hero and villain it was just people who
were trying to survive during the events
of Civil War right you had the superhero
community that was split down the middle
there were no heroes or villains there
it was simply people who were against
registration and for registration so
there's been multiple instances over the
case of Marvel Comics wherever heroes in
the traditional sense are willing to
cast aside their own morality for the
sake of a greater cause and that's the
point that he makes he says you value
your principles and your honor but these
are words and Concepts and in intangible
things with the luxury of choice they
are indeed to be protected but people
there's no choice when it comes to
protecting people that is what Heroes do
so when you have to choose between
giving me the knowledge I seek I.E how
to lower the shield thus portraying your
principles or watching as I Slaughter
your mortal population you will grit
your teeth and give me what I want and
that's the accurate statement that's
really exactly what would happen here
that the idea of the Avengers standing
with their arms on their hips in this
Superman pose and saying we're good guys
and we do good things and no way we're
going to give ground to a villain it's
standing on ceremony right it's
political grandstanding and really
nothing more now the cool thing about
this is that in response to that Captain
America suddenly shows up kind of
longing for a fight it doesn't amount to
much but he does come with a bit of a
caveat and this is where we explain the
nature of like the celestials and all
this kind of different stuff right so
for those of the guys who don't really
know what mbodies are in Marvel Comics
what it comes to Cosmic entities
eternity Infinity any number of these
guys with the exception of Galactus if
we're being honest they have no physical
form right like they just kind of
represent ideas when a cosmic entity
wants to appear with a physical form it
travels to a place called the dimension
of manifestations which is home to a
being called anthropomorpho this was
explained in the old Quasar Comics back
in the early 1990s back when Greg
capullo was drawing at Marvel for those
of you guys who read the Batman run and
didn't know that uh but when this
happens of course they get a physical
form then they appear and that's
basically it with regards to the
celestials and how they function in all
of this the idea behind this is that in
recent years in Marvel for those of you
guys who are unfamiliar with this the
beyonders were just like beings who
existed out there beyond the Multiverse
and that's all we ever really got what
ended up happening during Al Ewing's
really Defenders Beyond and even the
main defender's story is we learned that
the beyonders were created by the
celestials due to the celestial holy war
or that happened at the very beginnings
of all creation and the idea was that if
for some reason the celestials in any
one particular Universe went to war
against themselves again the beyonders
would be able to step in with this
astronomical amount of power that they
have and they would stop the fight
between the celestials potentially even
wiping out the entire universe so they
were created as a kind of checks and
Bounds that's why when Captain America
shows up here he's drenched in Celestial
blood because what the statement is
that's made here is it's simply that the
beyonders and even the lost one got his
power from the celestials but there was
a caveat built into it which is that
they cannot actually harm celestials
unless the celestials are Waging War
against each other so kind of like a
magical binding or a power based binding
or something along those lines is this
being done as like a giant plot device
for the story absolutely it 100 is being
done that way
right but it does tie in very neatly to
what it is well maybe not neatly but it
does tie in to what Al Ewing has been
covering with Defenders Beyond or at
least what he did cover with that story
now transitioning over to the main
beyonder himself once he approaches his
memory his idea is to basically work
directly with the memory absorb it into
himself and then in turn he'll recall
everything that the lost one needs to
know it will not be a return to his
powers but it will give him the
information that he needs now such as it
is when it comes to the lost one
fighting Captain America with all this
Celestial blood on his body it really
kind of just comes down to a
hand-to-hand fight he does use things
like optic blasts and so on and so forth
they're shooting lasers out of his eyes
or whatever you want to call it but it's
not really using like the vast power
that's at his disposal and so the result
of this is that the fight happens kind
of the way that you would expect it to
right just a good old-fashioned knock
down drag out fight but in the midst of
all this the beyonder steps up and then
stops the whole thing and says I will
tell you exactly what it is that you
want to know but you have to agree to
give me back my power I want to become
one with the cosmos again and ultimately
The Lost One agrees right that what ends
up happening is the lost one scans the
mind of the beyonder learns how to
effectively shut down the shield and
then absorbs all the power of the three
beyonders who are serving as a battery
for the shield into himself he's not as
powerful as he used to be but he's a lot
more powerful than he was at the
beginning of this story and so when the
beyonder says return my power to me the
lost one says okay and then literally
just kind of disintegrates him right
dissipates him to where he goes back to
becoming one with the cosmos he just
doesn't really have a physical form
anymore he could reconstitute it at some
point in time if he chose to so it's
just a way for Marvel to put his
character on the back burner until they
decide to bring him back again but then
like t'challa shows up with the blood of
the celestial on him and there is a
little bit of a fight there but the big
question that's really being asked is
are you going to leave this world you
need to get out of here now the lost one
is really kind of operating with a bit
of a vendetta which is to say like I
mean I'm really half inclined to just
wipe out your whole earth if for no
other reason than the fact that you guys
were just inconveniencing me right so I
think I might do that now this is where
the Avengers arguably make a bluff and
what they say is that there are
satellites that are orbiting the Earth
right now that are powered with
Celestial energy right Celestial
technology and they're targeted directly
at you you do not have the ability to
stop the full power of celestial energy
that's just not going to happen right
like you were made by the celestials you
can presumably be unmade by the
celestials which really wouldn't make a
whole lot of sense if their whole job
was to stop the celestials but the fact
remains right we're going to destroy you
using these satellites initially he
doesn't believe them but initially he
dismisses it right like I detect no
Celestial infused satellites and I do
not believe that you would kill 8
million people not even to save 8
billion this is a bluff and the response
of Captain America is actually really
genius here it's like maybe it is maybe
it isn't maybe the celestial technology
G hides their presence from you do you
really want to take that risk are you
going to gamble your life and your
entire existence on the idea of proving
us wrong right if that's really what you
want to do then sure right we can fire
the satellite off that may or may not be
there and we can just see what happens
right like we'll eradicate 8 million
people on our world to save 8 billion
people you'll be dead and at the end of
the day hey you know maybe it really is
a small price to pay for the greater
good now knowing superheroes as we know
them that's not going to happen and I
would bet nine times out of ten that it
really is a bluff we never actually get
an answer to this instead the lost one
simply restores New York using his
powers and sets everything back to
rights following that he basically ends
up departing Earth as he agreed to do
and that's where the story ends with
that being said guys
if you want to get caught up on the rest
of Avengers Beyond which was a lot
better than this ending to be honest
make sure you click this link to the
playlist and I will catch you all later
peace